who is the greatest stand-up comic of
all time
Richard Pryor yeah real or just his
Prince's really yeah he was but Richard
would say that Charlie Chaplin was the
greatest of all time 1980 Murphy was
better than well that's your opinion you
know say I'm allowed to say yeah of
course this is what I feel everyone has
a right to their own opinion
it's not like I'm right and you're wrong
right I value your opinion just not more
than mine right back now listen you
wouldn't listen your estate is I'm not
more than mine in this case your opinion
does matter Richard is the Richard is
the king
what would the business of trees well of
course he would then Charlie did it when
it wasn't no noise to make people laugh
at you me say anything come on white
right
what's the Keaton come on in can't
forget them I got my physical from Carol
Burnett and Lucille Ball yes that's what
comedy was comedy when nobody was scared
to take a [ __ ] pie in the face who's
the boss stuff chocolates and a mouse
come on man but we're by our image
you're right about the comedy you always
have to stand up as a confronting person
you always keep the comedy first max